[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: It takes
more than good tools.
It takes someone who
can tell good stories.
SPEAKER 2: Who can
simplify the complicated.
SPEAKER 3: Experiment
with the expected.
SPEAKER 4: Inspire
the uninspired.
SPEAKER 5: Explore
the unexplored.
SPEAKER 6: Excite the boring.
Engineer new hands--
hands that wave hello.
SPEAKER 7: Mentor the mavericks.
SPEAKER 8: Make sense
of the nonsensical.
SPEAKER 9: Connect with
cultures far away--
SPEAKER 10: --while staying
close to those nearby.
SPEAKER 11: It takes
more than tools
to make a classroom special.
SPEAKER 12: It takes a teacher.
[END PLAYBACK]
RAJEN SHETH: All right.
Well, thank you all
for coming today.
My name is Rajen
Sheth, and I'm director
of product management
for Chrome and Android
in business and education.
And we want to talk
to you a little bit
about what we're doing here
at Google in education.
And so the video
that we just showed
was something that we
produced last year.
And really, what we've
been keying in on is
it really does take a teacher.
It takes a teacher to
really make a difference.
And so one of the things
that I love about conferences
like this is I
get to meet people
from various different
walks of life,
various different geographical
areas, different age groups,
all kinds of different things.
All of us-- one thing
that we all have in common
is that we were kids
at one point in time.
We all went to school.
We all had great teachers
that influenced our lives.
And so what I asked you to do
is to think back to that time.
Think about a great
teacher-- somebody
that actually made a difference
for you, that has actually
impacted what you've ended
up doing in your career.
So for me, my
favorite example is
a guy named Robert
Thomason, who you see here.
And there's a
picture of me that's
a little bit younger
than what I am right now.
And Mr. Thomason was my
fifth and sixth grade teacher
back in Colorado.
And he came into my life at
a very important juncture.
When I was in
about fourth grade,
I had a lot of potential, but I
was not showing that potential
whatsoever.
You know, I was
failing tests, I was
skipping homework assignments,
I was getting bad grades.
And everybody was worried.
My parents were worried,
my teachers were worried,
I was worried.
I was wondering, could
I cut it at school?
Would I have the interest in
school to be able to do well?
And then Mr. Thomason
came in, and he
changed my view of what
education and what teaching
is all about.
So I'll give you some examples.
Rather than just doing
multiplication tables,
Mr. Thomason came in
with a box of staplers.
And he handed us
these staplers and he
said, hand these out to friends
of yours or to your family,
and ask them what
they think about it.
Get data about do
they really like it?
Do they like it a little bit?
which one do they prefer?
And then come back
with that data.
And so we used that to
analyze data and try
to figure out who
liked what, and be
able to learn math in that way.
Rather than just teaching
us about wildlife
and about outdoor
plants, we actually
took a week-long camping trip
in the Colorado wilderness.
And so we went as
a group and learned
about how to navigate in
an outdoor environment,
and learned about animals,
learned about plants firsthand.
And then also got to
learn about each other
and really have a
bonding experience.
Rather than teaching us how to
write a five-paragraph essay,
Mr. Thomason had us
write persuasive letters
to figures that we
wanted to influence
and to companies whose
products we didn't like.
And so in my case, I actually
wrote letters to a presidential
candidate-- at that
time, Gary Hart--
and also wrote to our
state senator, Tim Wirth.
And then I also wrote
to Wesson Oil Company
because my mom's oil bottle
was leaking in the cabinet,
so I wrote them a
strongly worded letter
to complain about that.
Amazingly, I got
replies from everybody.
I got a handwritten letter from
Gary Hart, handwritten letter
from Tim Wirth, and I
got a stack of coupons
from Wesson Oil who
I'm sure was pretty
amused that a 10-year-old was
writing them about a leaky can.
But these are things that have
stuck with me to this day.
And it's that kind of thing that
has really inspired me to learn
and inspired me to take
learning into my own hands.
And these are the
kinds of things that we
need to reimagine education.
And so the title of this
talk is a little deceiving.
It's not about technology
reimagining education,
it's about educators
reimagining education.
And how can we empower
those educators
to do great things
with their kids
to be able to then really
reimagine education?
And this is even
more important now
than it ever has
been in the past,
because a lot of the
things that were important
when I was growing up in terms
of just getting knowledge
into your head aren't
nearly as important.
So as an example,
I had to memorize
the list of all the presidents
in the United States.
And I can recite for
you 1 through 45 who
the presidents are.
However, what I
realized later is
that it wasn't important to
know that Thomas Jefferson was
the third president
of the United States.
It's more important to know
what exactly did he do?
How did that impact the United
States and the rest of history?
What can we learn from that?
Those are the kinds of
things that are important.
A lot of the rest
of it we can now--
any of our kids can now pull
out phones and look them up
in three seconds,
whereas for us, we'd
have to go to a library
to be able to look up
that kind of information.
These are the things that
we need to start to teach.
How do you use that
knowledge as opposed
to just the knowledge itself?
And in fact, one of the
interesting things we did
is we actually worked
with the Economist Group
to talk to employers and try to
figure out what types of skills
do they see as really
necessary to be able to succeed
in the workplace?
And these are the
results that came back.
And this is from
senior executives
of a lot of different companies.
The really interesting
thing, if you look at the top
five, and really
almost all of it--
very little of it has to
do with the knowledge that
is in your head.
All of it has to do with
how you work with each other
and how you use the
knowledge in your head,
and how do you actually
create new knowledge?
Things like creativity
and critical thinking.
Those are the kinds
of things that we
need to be teaching
in schools, and those
are the kinds of things that
we need to really orient
our technology towards.
So one big question
that comes up
is does technology really
improve educational outcomes?
And that really depends.
You've seen studies which
show that technology
makes no difference.
You've seen studies that show
it makes a negative difference.
Many, many that show that it
makes a positive difference.
And what I really think is
it's asking the wrong question,
because technology is
not the driver here.
It's about how you
use that technology.
And so we believe that
technology is a tool,
and used correctly, it can
make amazing differences
in the classroom.
And so part of what I want to
talk about today is how can you
use technology to make a
difference in the classroom,
and what are some
of the principles
that you can adhere to?
And then talk to
you about how we're
designing our technology to
adhere to those principles,
as well.
And then finally, hear
from a set of educators
who are actually doing
this and can tell you
more about what they've seen.
So at Google, we have really
been involved in education
from day one.
Google, if you look at it, was
founded at Stanford University.
Was google.stanford.edu for many
years before it incorporated.
It was started by
two founders who
were sons of college
professors, and so it's really
rooted in education.
From the very first day
when we had Google search,
schools started
using Google search,
and that was a key
tool in education
and has been since the
founding of Google.
And then about 11
years ago, in 2005--
at the end of 2005,
beginning of 2006--
we started to
actually think about
how can we improve the school?
How can we help schools
bring technology in?
How can we help teachers?
And that's when we launched
G Suite for Education,
which at the time was known
as Google Apps for Education.
It started with Gmail.
That was the only
app that we had.
And then it has
expanded to a variety
of creative and
collaborative applications.
On top of that, then, we
added Google Classroom,
which is really kind of the
mission control for all of this
for a teacher, and
lets them guide
what's going on in the
classroom in a much better way.
And then we added Chromebooks.
And one of the key problems that
we heard from a lot of teachers
was OK, great, I have
all this technology,
but how do I have my kids get
access to this technology?
If they can only use it one
hour a week in the computer lab,
it doesn't really
make a difference.
They need to be able to
use it on a daily basis
for me to be able to
change curriculum,
and that's where
Chromebooks really came in--
giving people an affordable,
manageable, secure,
and shareable way to bring
computing into the classroom.
And we've gone beyond that with
things like Google Expeditions,
making it so that you can have
virtual reality experiences,
and visit a far-off
land while sitting
in a school in California.
Those kinds of experiences
are now possible
with the technologies
that we have.
And we're going to continue to
innovate to make things better
for teachers.
Now, to figure out how to
best impact education, one
of the things we
did was actually
took a step back from this
to try to really figure out
the kinds of principles that
we want to be able to foster.
And so we actually worked with
the Columbia University Teacher
College to try to
figure out what
are some of the characteristics
of really successful schools,
or schools that are using
technology in a great way,
or schools that
are just succeeding
in one way or another?
And can we boil it down
to a set of principles?
And we came up with
four principles
that came out of that research.
So the first thing is
that learning should
be personalized and measured.
If you tailor the learning to
the needs of the individual,
they will be able
to learn better, as
opposed to just teaching
the same thing to everybody
in the classroom.
And that's an easy
concept to understand,
but it's hard to actually do.
If you're teacher and you have
30 students in your classroom,
it's very hard to
differentiate the learning
to every single kid, but this
is where technology can help.
In addition to that,
learning should be measured.
And so we think
about measurement
in a lot of cases as
high-stakes assessments
that happen at the
end of every year.
Measurements should be going
on on a constant basis,
and really, to give
feedback to the student
about what they're good at,
what they need help with,
where they can move forward--
those kinds of things.
And then feed that
back into the education
and tailor the education
even more to their needs.
So great example
we saw of this is
Charlotte-Mecklenburg schools.
And so Charlotte-Mecklenburg
is one of the largest school
districts in the United States--
140,000 students.
And they went one to
one with Chromebooks,
so all of their students
now have Chromebooks.
And they've been able to
see amazing things that
have happened in terms of
how they can actually now
get personal with learning now
that they have Chromebooks.
And so for example, they
now have digital classes
that students can use if
they fall behind in something
or if they need to understand
something a little bit more.
Or they can do live
one-on-one sessions
when they need it to be able
to interact with the teacher
when they need help.
Those kinds of things.
So a student that's a little
bit behind can catch up.
They also came with this
idea of the genius hour.
So students that were ahead
and that were feeling bored--
they can get a Chromebook
and they can go and research
anything that they
wanted to research,
and then be able to go and
present that back to the class
as part of this genius hour.
So amazing things
like that you can only
do now that you have
technology in the classroom.
Since they started
implementing technology,
they saw their graduation
rate increase from 70% to 90%.
And a lot of that they credit
to the amount of engagement
that they now see that students
have with school in general.
Second principle is
that learning should
be collaborative and diverse.
And what we mean by
that is that students
need to learn how
to work together,
and they also need to learn how
to absorb diverse viewpoints
and reconcile that together.
And this is something, again,
where we think that technology
can really, really help.
An example of that is McKinnon
Secondary School in Australia.
What they were able to do is now
that they had technology there,
they were able to bring
in collaborative tools
with things like Google Docs,
things like Google Classroom.
Students were starting
to use that to ask
questions of each other, and
help each other with homework.
They would comment on
each other's documents
and help each other get
better at writing documents.
And the teachers can actually go
in and comment on the document
while the student is
writing it to give them
real-time feedback.
That kind of feedback is
something where they can now
start to work with each
other and bring it and accept
a lot of diverse viewpoints.
And they're a very
diverse school district,
so they were able to actually
bring in multiple viewpoints
as a result of that.
The third principle is
that learning should be
project-based and self-managed.
And so if you give students
ownership of the learning,
that learning will stick
in a much better way.
I told you about the
examples that I had,
about writing
letters to senators
and presidential candidates.
I remember that because
I took ownership of that.
That was something
that was mine.
And so those are
the kinds of lessons
that really, really matter.
An interesting
statistic we saw is
that it is very likely the
vast majority of people that
are graduating from
college right now
will end up down the line
some time in a career that
doesn't exist today.
What that means is that
what they learned in college
will be somewhat
valuable, but they're
going to have to learn
more and more on the fly
to be able to do
what they need to do.
And so that skill of being able
to manage your own learning
is really, really critical.
An example we saw of this
is in Maine Township High
School in Chicago.
There's a set of kids
there that started what
they call the Chrome Depot.
So they were able
to actually create
their own little business
to be able to help kids
with Chromebooks and help
kids with technology.
They did this all on their own.
They started, as you can
see, an actual physical place
that kids could come to.
And what happened is that they
had to learn a lot of things
that nobody could actually
come and tell them.
They couldn't go to
a teacher to learn
how do you repair a Chromebook,
or how do you do x, y,
and z with a such-and-such tool?
They had to learn that, and they
ended up becoming the experts,
even more so than
their teachers.
That kind of learning
is the kind of thing
that will stick with them
now for a very long time.
And the fourth principle
is that learning should
be conceptual and experiential.
Back to the example of
the list of presidents--
it's not about the
knowledge, it's
about what you do
with that knowledge.
How you take that knowledge
and create concepts about that,
and how do you experience it?
So an example we saw of that is
[? Olou ?] school in Finland.
What they wanted to do is
teach their kids about Africa.
And so I think about how
I learned about Africa.
I learned about it as a map
with a bunch of countries,
and learned a little
bit about a few
of the countries here and there.
What they did is they actually
had their kids plan out a trip
to Africa.
So the kids could
figure out a country
that they wanted to
go to, they would
have to research that
country using the Chromebooks
that they had in the classroom,
and plan out a trip itinerary.
And then they
could actually take
the trip using
Google Expeditions
and actually experience that
country, be able to go there
and see what that was like.
That kind of experience
gives them a much better idea
of what Africa is
all about, and lets
them start to not just
have that knowledge,
but also bring it to concepts.
So then given this, how do we
design technology for schools
to make it such
that we can adapt
to these kinds of
environments and help
these kinds of environments?
So one of the first
things that we've
been realizing, especially
over the last year,
is that we need to
design for versatility.
How we think, for example,
a device is going to be used
is maybe not how it's
going to be used,
especially as students try
to do things by themselves.
As many of you know, when we
first released Chromebooks,
they were released as laptops.
And most of the
Chromebooks out there
are essentially in a
laptop form factor.
But we've been asked by
students and by teachers
to do all kinds of things
with these devices--
everything from turning them
into tablets to turning them
into notebooks to turning them
into books to turning them
into microscopes, for
example, or turning them
into virtual windows
into a virtual world--
those kinds of things.
And so one of the
things that we just did
is we released a whole
set of Chromebooks
that are convertible
and that are
versatile to be
able to turn them
into a tablet, a
notebook, a textbook,
and whatever you need it to be.
So it folds over, you're able
to turn it into a full tablet.
You have a stylus with it so
you can be able to write on it
and do all kinds of things.
The hardware is part
of that, but then you
also need to design for
versatility in terms
of the software itself.
And so one thing that
we recently released
is the ability for Chromebooks
to run all Android apps.
And so now, you can run apps
from the Google Play Store,
and be able to get
access to a whole host--
millions-- of
applications that can
do all kinds of interesting
things, especially
for education.
And so that has really made
it so that these devices can
be used for even more scenarios
than we would have ever dreamed
of.
The next thing is that
we design to empower.
How do we empower students
and empower teachers
to do great things?
One of the first examples
of this was Google Docs.
We knew that for decades
students and teachers
collaborate on documents,
and that people
try to collaborate on papers.
And when I was in school,
that was I write a paper,
take that piece of paper,
hand it to my teacher,
they mark it up, and
hand it back to me.
What we now have is
the ability, of course,
to be able to
collaborate in real time.
And that makes it so that you
can collaborate with students
from student to
student or student
to teacher in a much
more seamless manner.
By designing that as a core
principle of the product,
we make it so that the product
itself is more powerful
and fosters that
collaborative nature.
We're also now starting to
make things even more personal.
An example of this is Google
Classroom, where we now
can send you a personal alert,
and send personal alerts
to parents, as well, about
what the child has been doing
and how they're doing.
What are things that are
up on tap for next week?
What were the activities
for them this week?
Those kinds of things.
And be able to give
them a better sense
of their own personal agenda.
And then we're now even
taking that a step further
and starting to incorporate
machine learning.
And we're really just
at the cusp of this,
and there's a lot more
that I think we can do.
But an example of this is adding
superpowers to spreadsheets.
And what I mean by that
is you have a spreadsheet
with a bunch of numbers--
how do you actually draw
concepts from those?
So now we have the ability to
actually ask Google a question
about that spreadsheet, and then
be able to figure out answers.
So for example, you
can ask, in this case,
is there a correlation
between age and dexterity?
And it'll actually
look at the spreadsheet
and look at the data and be
able to give you back an answer.
This is useful for
students in a lot of ways
to draw concepts out of data.
It's also useful for teachers.
If a teacher, for
example, uses Google Forms
to be able to do these
ongoing assessments,
they can use that to draw
concepts and draw conclusions
about are there concepts
that they're missing,
or the whole class is missing,
or a certain set of people
are missing?
Those kinds of
things you can now
start to do because
of machine learning.
And last but not least,
we design for scalability.
We talked about access,
which is a key thing.
How do you get access
to this technology
to every single
student, and make it
so that they have that
technology available?
That's not an easy thing to do.
You know, it's all about
how do you get devices out
to these students?
How do you actually
maintain those devices?
How do you make sure you
don't turn your teaching
staff into IT support
when you do that?
And those are principles we
really designed Chromebooks
around.
When we designed
Chromebooks, we really
wanted to take a
step back and make it
so that we were designing
something that was really,
kind of, taking computing
to the next level.
So we made it simple so that
anybody can pick it up and use
it without any instruction.
We made it affordable so you can
finally get a computer starting
at $200.
We made it secure.
We turned the security
model on its head
and added manageability
as a key part of this such
that you're able to
manage the device
and make sure that your users
have a secure experience.
And one last thing,
which we didn't
realize was critical at the
beginning but was critical,
is sharability.
I can pick up any
Chromebook and log into it
and get all of my applications,
all my data, everything,
in seconds.
So what that means is you can
have a cart of Chromebooks.
30 students can walk
into that classroom,
pick up a Chromebook,
log in, and start
to do their work within seconds.
The next class walks in,
they do the same thing.
And so with 30
Chromebooks, you could then
serve 180 students
all throughout the day
as more students walk
into that same classroom.
Those kinds of
concepts make it so
that you can start
without having
to go full one to one
with these devices.
So I started with
talking about the past,
and before I bring
up the educators,
I want to talk a little
about the future.
So these are my two kids.
[INAUDIBLE] is my
older daughter.
She's seven years old.
And [INAUDIBLE]
is my younger son.
He's four.
And so as many of us
do, we try to describe
what we do at work to my kids.
So I try to tell them.
They mostly think I just
go to meetings all day,
which is actually true.
But one day, my daughter
came home from school
and she said, Daddy, do
we have a Chromebook?
I want to log in with
my Google Apps account.
And I was just
absolutely shocked
and thrilled all
at the same time
because that was my
entire career right there.
So as I started to
explain this to her,
she was like, yeah, whatever,
just get me the Chromebook
so I can start doing
what I want to do.
And so I gave her the
Chromebook, and she logged in
and she started to do
all kinds of things.
She uses technology like
i-Ready to start to learn more
about English and math.
She uses technologies
like Newsela
to have a kid's
view on latest news.
A variety of other types of
programs, things like Raz-Kids,
to be able to have
access from home
to a massive library of content.
Things like that
that she wants to do.
She wants to come
home and she wants
to do these kinds of things,
and that kind of engagement
and that kind of
love of learning
is the kind of thing that's
going to carry her really far.
Actually, last weekend,
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
were talking, and [INAUDIBLE]
said something and [INAUDIBLE]
said something, and she
said, [INAUDIBLE] I'm
using the literal
meaning of that, not
the figurative meaning.
And so [INAUDIBLE], being four,
kind of looked at her strangely
and went off and
played with his trucks.
But then I asked her,
how did you know that?
Where did you learn that from?
Because she's in first grade.
She said, oh, I learned
it from i-Ready.
So these are the
kinds of things she's
able to pick up on her own
now, and move at her own pace.
And so those kinds of things
are the types of tools
we're going to be able to
give the next generation
of students, and give them
a much better experience
than what we had.
So with that, I'd
like to actually
have you hear from
a set of educators
that are really doing this.
So I'd like to bring up
Roland Antoine, who's
the deputy chief of technology
for Dallas Independent School
district.
He has a masters in
educational psychology
and has been in education
in Texas since 2005-- first
as a teacher, then as
an assistant principal,
and then he's moved
into technology,
and now he leads the Dallas
ISD, Information Technology
Department.
One of the things he did is
he headed the ETE, Elementary
to Engineers initiative,
to actually start
to put computer science
into the early grades.
And I want to introduce
David Vannasdall, who
is superintendent of Arcadia
Unified School district.
He has a doctorate in
urban education leadership,
and became an educator
in 1992 in Cincinnati
to start off with, then
moved to Arcadia in 2005,
and is now the
superintendent there.
He's also helped launch AUSD's
annual Arcadia Innovation
Summit, which brings
together schools
from a variety of different
places in California
to have free
professional development.
And so we wanted
to bring them up
to actually talk about how
they're using technology
in the schools.
So thank you very
much for coming.
Just to start off
with, it would be
great to get an overview from
you about your districts.
Just tell us a little bit about
the context of your district.
DAVID VANNASDALL: All right.
I'll start off.
From Arcadia Unified
School District.
And we have about 10,000
students, TK through 12.
We're located right at the
foothills of the beautiful San
Gabriel Mountains in
Southern California.
We are an affluent
neighborhood, which
comes with some very high
expectations on the school
district.
Most of our students are hoping
to get into the Ivy League
schools.
ROLAND ANTOINE: So Dallas
Independent School District.
Now, how do I describe that?
We're an urban school district.
We have between
staff and students--
I like to describe
it as, like, a city.
So when I talk to
people about it,
we have 180,000
inhabitants of the city
that I like to talk
about as Dallas ISD.
And the reason why I do
that is because if you
were to put us on a scale of
cities in the state of Texas,
we'd be in the top 20
based on population.
So when we think
about things, we
have to think about scale in
a very interesting manner.
In our city, we're K-12, have
very diverse populations, OK?
Mostly low socioeconomic.
That means free
and reduced lunch.
So there are also some
significant economic challenges
that we have to deal with.
RAJEN SHETH: And so
Roland, you know,
you're from a very large
urban school district, very
diverse population, and in that,
how do you reimagine education,
and what are some of the
challenges that you've hit?
ROLAND ANTOINE: Well, as
part of a new leadership
team-- and we're, like,
barely a year old--
our first major imperative
is resource equity.
And for us, that means
meaningful access to technology
for everybody everywhere,
because in a city that large,
you might miss some things
and miss some people.
The reason why those
things are important
is for two reasons when
it comes to students.
First of all, that
every student have
access to technology as
a tool, because those
are the things that we
currently use in, you know,
post-secondary education
and in work environments.
The other one, and I believe
this one to be as important,
if not more important,
is access to technology
as subject matter.
What I mean by that is
areas like computer science,
like robotics, like
engineering, that involves that.
Part of what we did in 2015 is
we rolled out computer science
into every middle
school in the district.
So if you're a
student in Dallas ISD,
by the time you have
exited eighth grade,
you will have taken at
least coding or robotics
at some level.
Next year, we will be pushing
it down into elementary school
so that we can actually notch
up the level in middle school.
The reason why
that's important is
because in a large
urban school district,
students may not ever encounter
those learning experiences.
And if we don't do
that, there won't
be anybody to go to
this conference in 2027.
DAVID VANNASDALL:
That's a good point.
RAJEN SHETH: Well,
we appreciate that.
And David, you know, you're from
a very high-performing school
district here in California.
Similarly, what's your
approach to transformation?
DAVID VANNASDALL:
Rajen, we had to start
by grieving some
things that have
been very important to
education for over 100 years.
The first one was we had
to recognize that we're
no longer the experts.
Obviously, our students
can now Google anything.
That's more information
than a teacher has.
The second one was
that we're no longer
in control of the learning.
In fact, we realize that
some of our students
were learning in spite of us.
So we were disrupting
their learning
between the hours
of 8:00 and 3:00.
And the last one was that
students are no longer
motivated by grades.
They sincerely want to have
a purpose and a passion
for the work they
do, and they're
looking to have a voice.
And they're finding that
voice outside of school,
unfortunately, and
we had a desire
to help them find that
voice and get a voice,
and so we call that a device.
You can call it a device
for whichever you go with,
but that's actually the source
for students to perform,
to publish, to author.
And so we went one to one
over a three-year rollout.
And although we
call it one to one,
our students-- like many of
you, it's, like, four to one,
because you have one in your
pocket and a tablet, et cetera.
So that's why we also,
at the same time,
rolled out the G Suite for
Education for everyone.
It's our LMS
because we recognize
that kids are going
from one device
to the next all over
campus, space, and place,
and so it was just
seamless for them
to interact with their peers.
RAJEN SHETH: That's great.
Well, for both of you guys,
what are some examples
of transformation
that you've seen,
and where have you seen
this actually work?
DAVID VANNASDALL: I'll
jump in on something
that was just very exciting
to witness myself--
we had a student that, after
his junior year last year,
decided to go back to China
and spend some time help taking
care of his aging grandparents.
And while he was there, he
became increasingly frustrated
with the fact that three times a
day, he had to spend at least a
half hour dispensing medication
for his grandparents-- fumbling
around with the bottles, these
pills you give once a day,
these twice a day,
three times a day.
And he couldn't
leave during the day
because he had to
be there to do that.
So he came back to
school and decided
that he was going to commit
his maker space and genius hour
time--
and, of course,
having the ability
to collaborate with G Suite,
he decided to invent and create
a dispensary for
medication that could
be done over Wi-Fi on an app.
And he was able to
create a prototype,
and actually get it to market.
We'll see where it goes.
But that's that source of
passion that it started from.
It was a desire to
have a profound impact
on the community.
And obviously not just
his grandparents, but we
believe it's going to save
a lot of people, as well.
RAJEN SHETH: That's amazing.
Very cool.
Roland, how about you?
ROLAND ANTOINE: So
for this illustration,
I'm going to take
you to a second grade
classroom I recently visited.
And you don't really know
what's the effect of some
of the things that you do, kind
of looking for one thing, how
that actually turns into
something more interesting.
So I was on the campus.
I'm peeking into a second grade
classroom, kind of watching
what kids are doing.
I like to do that.
And so the way that we've
set up the Chromebooks
is where students
are immediately
taken to a Clever login page.
So when they log
into the Chromebook,
we use Google as an
identity provider.
They go to the
Clever login page,
and then they just
click an app and go.
They never have to log in
to anything ever again.
So the reason I did that was
to save instructional time--
a very notable objective.
I'm watching a student,
and they had just
finished working inside
a math curriculum app.
And since they had some
spare time in class,
they immediately flipped
over into code.org,
which we actually have it
available to all grade levels,
but formally only
in middle school,
and starts working
on an exercise
I guess his teacher had allowed
them to start working on.
And so this kid has moved
from mathematics to coding,
and the reason why
that's significant
is because this student, a
second grader, first of all,
is learning how to iterate
at a very early age.
Whenever you start working with
students in those populations,
failure becomes
this silent killer
of any type of curiosity,
because everything's a test,
everything's a grade,
everything is something
that either I pass or fail.
The other thing
is he now has been
exposed to something that
he would not otherwise
be exposed to.
So his view of what the
possibilities of his life
are vastly different
from the student who
never encounters that.
He knows of a very
different universe
where he can create
and do things
that other second graders in
some other school district
probably aren't even
aware of, especially
if you're in an urban area, like
the area where that school was.
RAJEN SHETH: That's amazing.
And you bring up
a very good point
about the concept of failure.
That you almost need to
teach that failure is OK
and that you need
to learn from that.
And that brings me
to my next question,
is that how do you actually
measure the impact of some
of these things?
Because traditionally,
a lot of that
has been done with test scores.
But how do you measure
things like that?
How do you measure impact?
DAVID VANNASDALL:
One of the things
that I'm not proud of is
in education for way too
long, we've been
defining learning
as just the acquisition
of knowledge, you know?
How much knowledge can
we jam in their head,
and usually store it in silos--
math, science, et cetera.
What we know now is learning
is what takes place--
well, I should say
authentic learning
is what happens when knowledge
intersects with application.
But it happens at a point of
intrinsic motivation, right?
That's that purpose.
There's a passion there.
And I'll give you
a quick example.
I gave you the example of
the student that did the app,
and that has a lot of
technology involved,
but here's one
that's as important.
I was visiting a student
in the hospital--
actually, a student's
parents in the hospital--
from our district.
And visiting with the
family, and there's
a knock at the door.
And two kids come in--
they didn't know me,
I didn't know them--
but they were carrying violins.
And they asked the family if
they could play the patient's
favorite song.
Now, the patient was asleep.
They shared the favorite
song with the students.
They didn't know that
song, and they said,
we'll be back on Wednesday.
So they went back and they
learned and they mastered
and they worked on this song.
And they came back on Wednesday,
and the patient was awake,
and they played the
song beautifully.
It brought a smile
to this lady's face,
probably in one of the
lowest points in her life.
That wasn't for a grade.
It was not a motivation
to be best in the class.
It was truly to take the
knowledge and their love
of music, master a song that
was important to someone,
and then deliver it.
And that's where
learning is, and that's
the project base, that's
the motivation that we're
trying to tap into.
So you can't measure
that quantitatively,
but we're trying to figure
out how to measure it,
because that's
where we're headed.
RAJEN SHETH: That makes sense.
ROLAND ANTOINE: We
actually have a couple
of ways of running at that.
So we do use
BrightBytes Clarity.
That's our quantitative measure,
because as we kind of move
along this path, we want
to be able to kind of look
at how things progress
for individual schools
so if we do need to consider
different ways of approaching
things or different
directions to point people in,
we can do that.
The reason that we are
doing things the way we are
is so that we can be very
flexible with the model
of implementation at
each individual school.
Now, the qualitative
measures, which are actually
a little bit more fun.
So every year, we have
this thing called STEM Day.
And inside that, we have
this little competition
called Tech Fest where
students submit projects.
And I'm a judge.
The last couple of
years, most of them
have been interesting
videos, slide presentations,
things of that nature.
So as I'm going through
the electronic submissions,
all of a sudden I start
running into animations
built using Scratch.
And understand these are
coming from fifth graders.
So I'm now beginning to see
this a very different approach
to using technology
in this exercise.
And then a couple
of other fun things.
The first year of
our robotics program,
we had one of our
[INAUDIBLE] teams
go to nationals, which was
a huge surprise to them.
And we had two of
our VEX robotics team
also go to national
competitions.
And that's just after one year.
One of the VEX is actually
an elementary school team.
RAJEN SHETH: Wow.
That's amazing.
Well, so what's next for you?
What are you thinking
about in terms
of you've gotten this far.
What more do you want to do?
DAVID VANNASDALL:
One of the things
that has getting me up early
right now every morning
is big data.
I think the first
big jump we had
was letting go of the
knowledge, and the next one
learning-- putting
that in the hands of kids.
The next one is really using
big data to drive our decisions.
And so just an example.
We have an incubator group
on one of our campuses
that is currently using
Prediction API to do
virtual schedules for a
student before they even
show up at the school.
And we can optimize their
learning environment
by knowing that
they're not going
to be successful with that
class and that teacher.
Just an example of
what we're doing.
However, there's a lot
of ethical dilemmas
that come with that in
the field of education,
because if I know
that information, what
is my obligation at that
point to make those changes?
And does our structures support
those changes at this time?
Some big hurdles.
We have to answer them, though,
because we have this data.
This isn't in the future.
This is right now.
The field of education
has more data points,
I think, than any other
field, and we just
need to harness them.
RAJEN SHETH: How
about you, Roland?
ROLAND ANTOINE: Well,
as I said, we're
a new leadership team,
and so this imperative
of resource equity--
we still have a good ways to go.
We're working hand-in-hand
with our school leadership
division to ensure
that by the time
we get around to
August of this year,
our campuses are in
a position to where
that is not an issue anymore.
So that's the first
stage of that.
And I just got an email
after we spoke earlier
that our initiative
for pushing computer
science into elementary is
going before our board, like,
tomorrow.
RAJEN SHETH: Great.
DAVID VANNASDALL: I'll add, too,
if you don't mind real quick--
Vision API.
This is one of the things that
just made so much sense to us
when it was brought to us,
is that every one of our kids
is sitting in front
of a camera all day
long, whether it's their phone
or it's the device, the laptop.
So, you know,
harnessing the strength
of Vision API for a teacher.
They can only look at
one student at a time,
but knowing the emotions that
is going on across the classroom
and being able to
be alerted to that
and intervene before a
behavior even happens--
I mean, imagine that.
And we have that
technology right now.
So just being able to go
to scale with it and use
it is very, very exciting.
RAJEN SHETH: Yeah, definitely.
DAVID VANNASDALL: And
I'm hoping someone out
there is going to
take our big data
and use TensorFlow to just
do some dynamic things.
RAJEN SHETH: Well, so
last question for you
is that, obviously, you have
the technology that's there,
but you have a lot
of constituents.
You have the students,
the teachers, the parents,
the community.
How do you bring everybody
along on this journey?
ROLAND ANTOINE: Very carefully.
There's a lot of communication
that has to occur,
because you're not only talking
about students and teachers
and administrators,
but, of course, you're
talking about board members
in a large district.
Everything can become
political, so you
have to be able to communicate
very clearly about things.
Also being able to demonstrate
some victories-- again,
like robotics
competitions; again, places
where people can encounter
students actually doing
the things that you're trying
to explain to them verbally.
That's how you do that.
RAJEN SHETH: Makes sense.
DAVID VANNASDALL: Yeah, the
more school increasingly
looks different than when
parents were in school,
we have to do more and more to
educate parents and bring them
along.
It scares them.
All of these
transitions-- the kids
are more fluent on the
technology than they are.
I believe schools
are having to work
as hard to educate parents and
bring them along as students.
And for us, the
data, the big data--
and this is just in here, right?
So no one-- you know,
it scares our parents.
It completely
scares them when you
start talking about sharing
their data and using it.
But I think if we bring them in
and share with them how we're
using it and the
amount of predictions
that we can make that's going
to increase and optimize
their student's
learning, I think
they'll be right there with us.
But we have to do a better
job of bringing them along.
RAJEN SHETH: That makes sense.
[MUSIC PLAYING]